mais surtout ce qui fait vraiment le
point fort de ce n fun max pro c'est
tout simplement
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'un
smartphone des zus que j'ai dans les
mains depuis quelques temps pas trop
trop encore eu le temps de m'en occuper
mais je m'en occupe c'est le zen fun nax
pro 2 au tour au studio alors je vous
explique ça peut être un petit peu
complexes comme ça j'étais à milan je
suis de retour dans le studio
on teste un peu tous les côtés parce
qu'un smartphone sas teste sur le long
terme et pas que sur ce coup comme ça je
vous ai fait toute la partie photo vidéo
découverte à milan ça fait quelques
jours je suis dessus que je teste en
préambule jean mercier team qui m'a
laissé un message super sympa sur sa
chaîne youtube merci steam je vous
laisse regarder
monsieur gros si tu regarde cette vidéo
je suis fan de toi et je suis vraiment
fan de toi parce que tu fais des belles
vidéos jeux les complète et c'est
vraiment dommage tu mérites le million
d'abonnés
je vous invite à les laisser un petit
message un petit commentaire à steam je
vous ai mis le lien social dans la
description crois que ça lui fera super
plaisir
un smartphone qui vient compléter la
gamme iphone de cette année l'iphone 5
l'iphone 5 zz top 5 light et là on a le
jeune femme ex pros alors la question à
se poser c'est à quoi sert ce aux iphone
max pro combien il y est situé un petit
peu par rapport à tout ce qu'on a cette
année du côté de chez asus est pas mal
de produire tout vous mettre là parce
que voilà ça sera mieux qu'est-ce qui va
apporter par rapport aux différents
modèles de asus de cette année et est ce
que ce zenfan max pro est cool oui non
qu'est ce qu'il apporte des nouveautés
comme van der sar à vous avez compris
donc je vous présente ce produit comme
d'habitude s'il vous intéresse vous a
mis un lien en bas d'un description
bouvier et on va tout de suite commencé
par ouvrir la boîte au top
voilà we love photo on l'ouvré vous
tirez la pratique langue est le
smartphone est juste là pour l'ouvrir
regarder j'en profite là je suis à milan
hop je profite de vous montrer ça voilà
le smartphone le design est assez sobre
en tout cas il est pas comme ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on connaît déjà le
module photo c'est vraiment petit par
rapport à ce qu'on peut retrouver
actuellement sur le marché
c'est assez marrant mais un côté un peu
minimaliste dedans capteur d'empreintes
digitales placé
ici la marque asus là la connectique
c'est du micro usb on a un haut parleur
ici priziac plutôt cool bouton volume
ici bouton on off
voilà assez simple assez efficace comme
ça plutôt pas mal dans la boîte ensuite
on a ici hop un câble usb micro usb des
écouteurs bien évidemment le bloc
d'alimentation créé ici de couvrir votre
tiroir de cartes sim et une petit dock
voilà ça c'est déjà cool le syphon ax
pro c'est un petit peu la réponse de
asus aurait deux minutes cinq de shiro
me vous avez un écran de 5,99 pouces
2160 par 1080 pixels une dalle ips1
c'est du lcd en termes de puissance
intérieure vous avez un stade dragon's
636 couplé à 3 giga de ram
le gpu est une adreno 509 il a 32 gigas
de stockage que vous pouvez monter grâce
à une carte micro sd jusqu'à 512 giga
mais surtout ce qui fait vraiment le
point fort de ce n fun max pro c'est
tout simplement sa batterie une énorme
batterie de 5000 millions terreur avec
ça franchement vous êtes quoi voir venir
parce que si vous comparez ne serait ce
que par rapport au galaxy note 9/10 une
batterie de 4000 milliampères heures si
vous regardez par rapport au pos cofondé
francs et d'une batterie de 4000
milliards perdre également s'ils ont
regardé par rapport aux honneurs plaît
il est une batterie de 3750 militaire
heure là vous avez deux batteries de
5000 milliards terreur il fait vraiment
sa force c'est son autonomie si vous
n'êtes pas trop gourmand si vous n'avez
pas une utilisation hyperintenses il a
joué toute la journée puis à vous
défoncer les yeux on va pas se mentir
vous pouvez le tenir quasiment deux
jours et en plus de ça il a des
recharges rapides
autant dire qu'une batterie 5 millions
terreur si vous la recharge est pas
rapidement vous risquez d'y passer un
petit moment donc ça c'est aussi un
point très positif
le truc qu'on procède en dit peut
regretter c'est qu'il n'est pas de la
recharge en usb type c mais en micro usb
par contre ce qui est bien c'est qu'il
est un bluetooth 5.0 ça c'est aussi un
point qui est top
c'est un produit qui est dispo depuis le
mois d'août de cette année donc il est
franchement hyper hyper récent et que en
tout cas moi je trouve plutôt cool l' os
c'est un android stockent android 8.1
oreo il est efficace vous avez ici votre
tiroir d'appli avec vos petites applis
vous pouvez rechercher vos applications
ici ça marche plutôt bien c'est fluide
ça répond bien
on n'a rien à lui reprocher je trouve
que l'écran fait le taff laverie hop je
le pousse à fond il est très lumineux et
il pèse 180 g autant vous dire que
franchement il est relativement léger
côté photo vous avez un premier capteur
de 13 mégapixels avec l'ouverture de f
2.2 un deuxième de 5 mégapixels avec une
ouverture de f 2.4 et l avant vous avez
un capteur de 8 mégapixels qui vous
permettra de faire quelques scènes fille
plutôt tranquillement vous pouvez régler
pas mal de choses hein ça c'est sympa
vous pouvez régler les iso l'exposition
la balance des blancs a tenté
d'enfreindre à côté vidéo franchement ça
promet pour est fine et bien évidemment
en 1080p
vous pouvez aussi filmé en 4k usd ou en
4k dci
alors je sais pas si le si vous voyez
l'intérêt pour vous deux films en 4k en
tout cas si vous voulez le faire vous
pouvez faire vous devez régler la
balance des blancs vous pouvez checker
votre stockage enregistré un lieu la
durée de la vidéo il ya pas mal de
petites choses qui sont possibles là
dessus tous vos paramètres sont là c'est
plutôt cool tu as intuitif on peut
passer bien évidemment au plat sur la
caméra celle fissa à lui comment ça va
on va repasser là que ce sera un petit
peu mieux vous avez ici quelques filtres
si vous souhaitez les maîtres le micro
vous pouvez couper activée et lorsque
vous êtes sur le mode photo ici vous
avez bien évidemment hop les réglages le
hdr mode portrait nom revient ici mode
portrait sport fleurs rétroéclairage
nuit bon ça c'est tous des petits
paramètres pour vraiment embellir vos
photos parce qu'il est intéressant
surtout le hdr high dynamic range pour
avoir une vraie vraie vraie meilleur
rendu de photos voyez là je bascule sur
les caméras avant j'ai vachement de
lumière sud en mode photo ça c'est pas
mal c'est quand même assez venus surtout
que la spa six voiliers mais je suis
quand même vachement à contre-jour donc
je trouve que c'est pas mal ça reconnaît
mon visage extrêmement bien je peux pas
manière l'appareil je le perds la voyez
je me mets là je le perds un petit peu
ça revient très foncée et là tout de
suite il reconnaît mon visage et il fait
le focus sur mon visage assez rapidement
ça c'est plutôt pas mal souffre le
résultat est plutôt cool
alors là vous avez portrait plus
retouche d'image donc on est un petit
effet ben ok qui va se faire un petit
côté floutés ouais bon pourquoi pas
nécessairement ce qui a forcément être
le le plus intéressant vous avez bien
évidemment tous vos réglages là vous
pouvez enregistrer le lieu la taille de
l'image en 13 mégapixels 12 mégapixels
comme vous le souhaitez la qualité de
l'image est levé son art faible
retardateur le stockage
détection du visage vous avez vu ça
marche très très bien les iso en
automatique éviter d'aller trop parce
que tu te rajoute et du bruit
vous pouvez avoir deux lentilles bandant
cinquantaire 60 hertz réduction des yeux
rouges sont de l'obturateur celle-ci pas
mal moi je pense qu'en tout cas les
petites options qui sont proposés
nativement là dedans pour nous faire des
photos et de la vidéo
son standard efficace et plutôt bien
fichu lâche en train de filmer sur le
capteur arrière pour voir un petit peu
voir ce que ça dit en termes de
luminosité antennes de rancoeur je ne
vois pas je vais prendre la main je veux
les mettre devant un miroir comme ça se
verrait de ce que je vois de miroirs
salaire quand même plutôt pas mal je
vais me déplacer un petit peu changé de
pièces comme ça on va voir un peu ce que
ça dit en faible luminosité
ensuite dans une salle de bains vers la
lumière comment est ce que vous trouvez
est ce que vous trouvez que ce
smartphone film bien hop je le pose là
est ce que vous trouvez que le rendu est
plutôt correct pas correct est-ce qu'il
vous parie coule pas cool
vous marquez tout ça et nous voilà
maintenant on sent les caméras selphy
alors j'ai l'impression que écoutez
franchement il ya un peu de bruit là il
ya un peu de bruit sur mon visage alors
après c'est une lumière qui est vraiment
artificielle ici donc c'est pascal mieux
on est à l'hôtel on est à milan tout de
suite en italie je trouve néanmoins que
ça fait plutôt bien faire face et
lumière à l'éteindre mais je comprends
les monstres tels super ans et balas ans
et 5 étoiles
je crois que le truc est plutôt pas mal
alors je vous emmène à garder en vie
voix haute
on va aller on va bouger voir si la
stade est bien bas bien ça a l'air
plutôt pas mal quand même je trouve que
le rendu est pas mal là il ya du
contre-jour on doit encore toucher le
point sur moi parce que ça marche
non ça marche pas il ya du bruit j'ai
l'impression que de bruit chez moi
crochet d'une source vraiment de lumière
là bas est ce à dire qu'il a vraiment
cherché à compenser la langue et de la
lumière tout de suite en face de moi je
suis face à une fenêtre et tout de suite
ça va beaucoup mieux le rendu est
beaucoup plus qualitatif
c'est vachement moi j'aime bien parce
que je trouve qu'effectivement c'est un
smartphone qui se marque fred qui ont
faible luminosité ne va pas forcément
être hyper hyper hyper hyper cali d'un
autre côté il fait l affaire et va
chercher vraiment à compenser il va
monter dans les isolants forcément vous
allez attraper un petit peu de bruit là
desquels la lumière il fait jour 2 1
mais bon là la vue ou back time pour
vous la montrer desquels la lumière le
résultat est là et je trouve que c'est
vraiment en plus c'est assez naturel le
traitement d'image moi alors j'ai un peu
de bruit là derrière sur le fond la
balle à la la voile et l'aja là là il ya
un peu de bruit là mais dans l'absolu ça
fonctionnait sur pib g typiquement
lorsque je lance le programme
ils me proposent directement non pas une
configuration en mode élevé comme je
pourrais l'avoir sur un poco phone ou
alors sur un smartphone très puissant
avec un snapdragon 845
mais là sur celui-là il reconnaît
directement les performances sont assez
moyennes mais c'est normal c'est un
smartphone milieu de gamme
on est donc directement sur les
performances moyennes en terme de
graphismes le jeu est plutôt cool assez
fluide salak pacha
lors des visionnages c'est pareil à la
qualité de l'écran et bien vous pouvez
bien évidemment zoomer en venant runje
bon bah ça c'est un grand classique ça
marche plutôt bien même l'audio est pas
mal lorsque je vais le noter alors vous
avez un haut parleur mono qui est situé
juste là ici pas d'eau parleurs stéréo
que notre côté on est sur un smartphone
milieu de gamme on va pas non plus lui
demander la lune mais c'est vrai je
trouve que le rendu en termes de qualité
audio et vidéo et pas mal au niveau du
casque c'est aussi pas mal il ya du son
la qualité sonore est pas mal vous
n'allez pas forcément avoir la meilleure
qualité de son dessus mais pour aller
écouter de la musique sur spotify
regarder des vidéos sur netflix sur
youtube ou que sais-je encore
ça fait la sphère en plus il ya un peu
de puissance c'est pas le smartphone le
plus puissant mais une fois de plus
c'est pas la peine d'écouter la musique
à fond on n'est pas là pour cent en
dessous bon verdict avec plusieurs jours
d'utilisation de ce gène phone max pro
c'est un smartphone milieu de gamme
il a des points plutôt positifs déjà le
vraiment gros point positif c'est son
autonomie il a une autonomie qui est
vraiment énorme
ça fait un petit moment que j'utilise
maintenant et je vous dis les deux jours
vous y arriver sans aucun problème pas
non plus faire n'importe quoi et tout le
temps dessus a joué toute la journée au
quel cas effectivement l'autonomie va
partir par fondre comme neige au soleil
mais si vous l'utilisez normalement vous
jouez vous étonnez réseaux sociaux vous
rappeler vos emails pour des vidéos
faire des choses comme ça vous aurez
absolument aucun problème je le trouve
globalement plutôt bien
il n'a pas succombé à la encoches ça
peut être aussi un point positif un
point négatif ça dépend de chacun le
design est très classique il se démarque
pas particulièrement par rapport aux
autres mais je dirais que pour avoir un
smartphone qui n'est globalement pas
trop cher qui est de bonne qualité qui
est très équilibré surtout avec une
grosse autonomie
le zune phone max pro est pas mal dites
moi ce que vous en pensez en commentaire
est ce qu'il vous séduit oui non est ce
que vous pourriez vous laisser tenter
par ce modèle est pour ce modèle stipule
mal et puis est-ce que
les produits d'asus cette année vous
plaise ou vous ont plu que ce soit le
iphone 5 le 5 ze5 light les iphone max
pro vous marquez tout ça en commentaire
et puis rester connecté vous allez voir
je vous réserve pas mal de surprises des
choses qui arrivent et ça va être plutôt
cool
[Musique]